The Prophet.
Why is that a bad thing? Use it.
Because all my since we talked.
Because you lose control.
Because I gain it.
Johnny, do you believe in me?
Paul, The trade are still alive.
Deal with this prophet.
Show me how you are.
No, Father
was a weak man.
This world is beyond cruelty.
You've been fighting the hurricanes
for decades.
My family's been fighting them
for centuries.
They were massacred
alongside my father.
My father didn't believe in revenge.
We believe in Fermin.
When you take a statement,
reload
the hashtag far this year.
He said.
I got that.
Thanks.
I won't be fighting for him.
I'm fighting for my people.
Young Puff,
even.
And there are signs.
Look who's back from the dead.
Don't do what must be done.
We gave them something to hope for.
That's not how
It's not a prophecy.
It's a story.
I will love you.
As long as I have read
this prophecy.
It's how they sleep. US.
I don't care what you believe.
I believe
I am all for trading
truth, humble rocket.
You can destroy a thing
as the real control that.
Welcome back, everyone
it's Charlie. Big surprise
New Dune part
2 trailer. We'll break it down.
There's a whole bunch
Easter eggs and references here.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The movie's coming out later this year
there's a bunch of new footage in this,
a bunch of new reveals and characters
that weren't in the last trailer,
we get our first look at Christopher
Walken.
Is Emperor Shaddam the fourth?
The backstory between him and Duke
Leto Atreides
is actually pretty interesting, too,
because they have so much history
that predates
the events of the first movie
or the first book.
The whole is,
even though the emperor is much
older than Leto Atreides
was he respected and admired him.
He was his adoptive cousin,
in a lot of people
believe that he wanted to betrothed.
His oldest
daughter, Irulan, played by Florence
Pugh to the Duke Leto Atreides,
but she was just too young at the time.
is certainly
would have solved a lot of problems
because he didn't have any male heir,
so people just assumed
that he would either marry his daughter
to another powerful member
of the landstrad
or he would wind up adopting another son.
And that son would take
the golden lion throne.
but the other big theory
is that a lot of people believe that
the reason why he secretly just didn't
go ahead and do that is just wait till
a ruling was old enough
to consummate the marriage with Leto
was all because of the bene gesserit order
A woman's mother, Shaddam's
wife in the mother of all of his daughters
was a Bene Gesserit, which unlike
Duke Leto, he had no regular highborn wife
before he was with Jessica.
So the emperor had always been
married to the Bene Gesserit, which
the belief is that originally the Bene Gesserit had other plans for Irulan
when she was born in their complicated
plan to create the quiz
and satire Act through the careful
Breeding Intermarriage program
between all the great houses and the land.
Strong was basically what they tell you
during the events of the movies,
in the books that they always wanted
Lady Jessica to give Leto a daughter
and wed that daughter to feyd.
Harkonnen,
who was the Baron's chosen heir,
he still is still alive in the movies
right now.
The baron has no natural son.
He's actually gay in the story,
so he doesn't actually have a wife.
But he chooses Fayed as his successor.
in a rule in marrying Leto outside of that
plan would have completely
thrown things off the rails, even though
that's ultimately what wound up happening
through the course of the story with Lady
Jessica giving birth to Paul, a son.
But at least early
on, Shaddam's power in the known universe
was completely dependent on the Bene Gesserit working behind the scenes.
So it was a very complicated web of Bene Gesserit plans that kept him in power.
in ultimately he just gave in
to their wishes for their larger long term
plans for the quiz that satirize.
So he just did
whatever the bene gesserit told him to do
when it came to his daughters
during the events of the movies,
they kind of want to make
him seem like that, like he's completely
dependent upon the Bene Gesserit advice.
so they're meant to feel like the ones
who really have the power in the universe
in the Emperor
only orchestrated the downfall of Leto
during the events of the first movie.
Much later in life,
after the Duke's popularity in the land
dried started to make him more popular
with all the great houses
than the Emperor himself.
so he slowly became more paranoid
over time.
But at that point,
he had been friends with Leto Atreides
He's not great friends, but
they both greatly respected each other.
it'll be really interesting
to see what Christopher
Walken's version of this character
is like during the movie.
we only hear a couple lines
of dialog from him when he's yelling
Apollo Treaties.
Sounds like it's happening
at the end of this movie
and we'll see if they wind up splitting
this movie into a part three as well.
the scene where he's yelling at Paul
about his father Leto being a weak man.
Seems like it's from this scene here
where they're all getting ready to fight,
where he's getting ready to fight.
Fayed Harkonnen
is sort of this big moment of him
offering an ultimatum to the emperor.
Like, either you acquiesce to my plan,
I'll marry your daughter, or ruin
and become the new emperor of the universe
and will control spice.
Or you don't agree.
And I'll stop all spice production in.
It will bring the gears of the universe
to a grinding halt.
No one will be able to travel anywhere.
it it basically take the entire universe
back to the dark ages it
as the saying goes, the spice must flow it
ultimately anybody in the universe,
that's all they care about,
no matter what faction they come from,
they just want more spice
because it is the means for them
to hold on to their power.
nobody's empires,
whatever faction they come from work.
If there is no spice.
one of the things you see
at the beginning of the trailer,
too, is it seems like Paul is slowly
entering into the Fremen society.
Tony is trying to tell him like,
no, no, no, they don't want to have you.
And he's like, Yeah, I got it.
They hate me.
and he slowly trying to win them over.
You saw this during the events
of the original David Lynch movie.
he slowly begins to train them
in the trade.
He's fighting ways as well as the bene
gesserit fighting techniques, making them
even more powerful against the Hawkins
and the emperors start a car.
most of the fighting you see in
the trailer is against the harkonnen.
So like all these armor suits or harkonnen
armor suits,
the baron comes back to Iraq.
Is this is his signet ring?
This being kiss,
this weird, oily substance that he was
bathing in this all over his fingers here.
This is them cleaning up the bodies
from the massacre of the atrocities
in the first movie
one of the other big things in the trailer
you notice is
there is way more of zendaya's
tiny character.
the director said that
she was just a much bigger
part of the story during the second movie,
which is why you didn't
see her in the first as much
she seems much more active in their raids
against the Hawkins
was he Paul encounter journey again
which is also something we saw
in the previous versions of the story.
he survived the Hawkins massacre
by throwing in
with another group of fremen
in a different part of the desert.
most of the people from the first movie
will be coming back for this.
Even Jason
MOMOA'S Duncan, Idaho character
will eventually come back into the story.
Won't really talk too much about that
because it kind of gets into spoilers.
Jason Momoa was joking about that.
Like just you wait, I'll be back.
Don't you worry. this
this whole conversation with Lady Jessica
and still Gar about belief in Paul.
What he believes
in over the course of the trailer,
you do see him become a believer.
Like it doesn't matter what's true.
I believe in this Ultimately,
it seems like he sees what Paul can do
and starts to believe in him.
you also hear Paul arguing about this
with Jessica later in the trailer, too.
In what they're talking about
is this whole myth of Deeb in the Savior
that the Fremen believe
are going to come in, rescue them
eventually or help save them in some way
And that's something
that the bene gesserit
have been orchestrating for a long time,
that for many years creating a prophecy
that will play into their plans
for the eventual arrival of the quiz
that Satyricon
So the Bene Gesserit can eventually
control Arrakis in spice production.
Because remember, spice is power.
Spice equals power in the universe
this this whole concept of the golden path
in the quiz that satirized
finding the perfect timeline for humanity
in leading them down that path.
but really just boils down to the Bene Gesserit wanting control of the universe.
during the first movie,
Paul and Jessica talk about this
when they arrive on Iraq, it's like this
whole idea of a savior, quote unquote.
And Jessica knows what's really going on.
Like, oh, yeah, this is a false prophecy
that the Bene Gesserit have cooked up.
so when the Haqqanis attack
and they need to survive,
they say we should play on this idea
of the prophecy.
We should just play.
And even though we think that is false,
we should pretend
like you are this mythical savior
being so at least at first.
Paul is knowingly misleading the Fremen,
causing them to believe
that he is that savior.
but ultimately, through his actions,
they all start to believe
he really is that savior.
So it's kind of like a self-fulfilling
prophecy there also plays into the idea
when he's telling Journey
that all these visions lead to horror.
in his dreams.
He sees all these people
committing atrocities in his name
and it horrifies him.
This is them getting ready
to take the waters of life.
And this is the previous
Freeman's reverend mother before Lady
Jessica becomes their new reverend mother.
she also winds up
having to take the waters of life
as part of that process
to within the story.
The water of life is literally the bile
of the baby.
Sandworms.
any of that,
they don't reference it in this trailer,
the big thing is that she's still pregnant
with her daughter,
with the Duke's daughter,
when she takes the waters of life.
And they're not really sure
what that's going to do to the baby.
I'm sure there'll be a lot of talk
about that when the movie comes out.
We'll see if they include
any moments like that in the trailer
because for the most part,
she's still pregnant.
During this early part of the story,
the events of the David Lynch
movie, kind of speed run,
the story of the first couple of books,
which is why you see Paul's
younger sister.
I don't know if we'll actually see her
during the events of due in part
to this scene of Paul
pulling the Chris knife
with everybody standing around him
is them getting ready to fight feyd
hearkening.
the Hoyt is that feyd
is meant to be the baron's other nephew
the son of his brother
who abdicated the throne,
allowing the baron
to become the baron in the first place.
He's meant to be Ribbon's younger brother
in the one who the Baron favors.
Even though ribbon is useful to him.
Ribbon is kind of like an animal.
Like a wild animal
the baron just uses to squeeze people.
fate is the person the Baron views
as his potential successor,
I think the all the black
and white scenes of feyd
fighting in the gladiator pits here are on
Katie Prime, the Hawkins Homeworld,
and it's Margot Lady Margot watching Fate
as part of her mission to seduce him
and get his genetic material.
one of the other big things during
the trailer footage, too, is that a ruling
seems like she's much more active in
the story than she was in the first one.
Even though they kind of imply
that during the events of the David
Lynch movie, she's the person
who ultimately chooses to accept
Paul's proposal
to marry her and him to rule the universe.
The emperor doesn't
want to be anything to do with it,
but she smartly realizes
that's the only path forward for them.
when you hear him saying
deal with this prophet,
he might actually be talking to the baron
or to feyd
even though I love the first movie,
it just feels like this
movie has so much more action.
It's sort of like the difference
between Avengers
Infinity War, in Avengers Endgame,
but in reverse.
Seems like they're hyping up
a huge rematch between Gurney and Ray-Ban.
Can't wait to see that the big line
they go out on in the trailer long live
the Fighters is
also right out of the books.
just in general it's a great trailer.
I think it's a lot
better than the first trailer.
there's so much new footage.
Is there any Easter eggs that I didn't
talk about during the video that you spot?
I just write them below in the comments.
You could talk all day
about what's going on here.
We're in the middle of Marvel's
Secret Invasion episodes.
My full episode
three video will post next week.
You can click here for that Episode
three video and click here to learn
about Ben Affleck coming back
as daredevil in Deadpool three.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!